un concert improvisé lors du conseil
municipal de maurepas l'image n'est pas
banal plus d'une centaine de personnes
s'étaient déplacées pour montrer leur
mécontentement contre la nouvelle
orientation culturelle du café de la
plage leurs craintes
la fermeture progressive du lieu j'ai
commencé là-bas en tant que bénévole et
maintenant je suis technicienne lumière
et c'est aussi grâce au café de la plage
que je fais ce métier j'ai pas envie que
ce genre de lieux fermés
pour moi faut que ça continue pour la
municipalité pas de fermeture du café de
la plage mais en raison d'une baisse des
dotations de l'état
la programmation a été réorganisé le
lieu est désormais dédié aux expositions
aux actions culturelles et à la
promotion des artistes locaux me paraît
important en tout cas de faire
comprendre que le café de la plage et
bien sûr utilisé entre autres par le
cobalt pour réunir les groupes qui le
souhaitent puissent toutes les musiques
de groupes locaux
vous pensez bien que nous avons besoin
comme dans toutes les structures
déficiences de mutualisation et c'est ce
que nous avons voulu faire un message
qui n'a pas vraiment réussi à convaincre
les manifestants
le fermer pendant quatre mois le
réouvrir pendant une date leur fermer
pendant quatre mois et le réouvrir
pendant une date à partir du moment où
il ya plus d équipes en place
parce que c'est le cas et à partir du
moment où ça ouvre aussi peu c'est à
dire trois fois basses et fermé
si on fait une saison qu'ils n'avaient
que trois dates dans l'année je sais pas
trop ce que ça veut dire mais l'année
prochaine on sait très bien que c'est à
dire ah bah n'y avait pas assez de
personnes donc du coup ils vont du coup
ils vont ils vont se dire bon ben on va
le faire mais comme ça c'est réglé
face à cette action
la municipalité a proposé aux
manifestants de solliciter un rendez
vous individuel